this too dramatic moment Jodie Chesney's
killers were caught the footage released
as 19 year old drug dealer Spencer
nongak we was sentenced to at least 26
years in prison for fatally stabbing 17
year old Jody his accomplice Aaron
Isaac's will spend 18 years in jail the
17 year old described as a willing and
enthusiastic supporter substantial
sentences which pleased Jody's close
friend Clara sharp who was there the
night she was killed
so happy overjoyed the you know I had to
resist cheering when the judge sentenced
them because you know they deserve it
they deserve all the time they get in
there they don't deserve short sentences
and they don't deserve anything less
Jodie Chesney had no connection to gangs
a victim of mistaken identity she was
sitting in a park with friends when she
was stabbed in the back the court heard
just how many people's lives have been
affected by the murder of Jody Chesney
15 heartbreaking victim statements were
read out from friends and family
describing the pain and anxiety they've
been feeling since her death ribbons in
Jody's favorite color
were tied outside court to remember her
a bright and kind young girl everything
he's seen in the papers and the news
about is true and she was
one of the coins she didn't know that
she was this special you never would
have guessed that she would Fed this
impact on everyone there's not a day
goes by that we don't circle no day goes
by that we don't think about her or
think what she would have been doing now
Jodie Chesney's family say they're left
broken the life of someone so funny
silly and talented needlessly cut short
Charlotte Lomas Sky News